somebody's had a terrific season so far
uh a sixth round selection out of
louisiana and the way that everything
broke in the backfield for the san
francisco 49ers they have been leaning
on this man to run the football i guess
when debo samuel is not he is uh one of
the best running backs in the nfl today
for the san francisco 49ers on a
three-game win streak joining us on the
mercedes-benz van phone line is elijah
mitchell how are you elijah
doing good how y'all doing i'm doing
better uh then for talking to you so
thank you for calling into this program
um how have you found your first season
going around in the nfl elijah
uh i found it going pretty uh pretty
well uh for my first year i just got to
keep keep building and keep uh
keep playing like how i'm playing where
were you on draft day when you got the
call in the sixth round walk me through
your drafting experience
uh i was in my hometown um in new york
louisiana okay and you were with family
is that where you where you were with or
what did you give me give me uh give me
the details on the day and and who
called you on that day yeah uh yeah i
was uh at home with family and stuff we
got running out of building uh
close to close to my home and everything
and uh you're just waiting around and i
got a call from uh
from uh kyle and and john lynch so that
was a uh that was one of the best days
of my life
so you look down at your phone and you
see an area code i imagine you wouldn't
know off the top of your head the area
code of uh
santa clara california right off the top
of your head
so and then you pick up the phone and it
was kyle that's the first one yeah yeah
it was uh actually uh it was uh my
position's cooked by the t and he put me
on the phone with kyle and uh
and john lynch
so uh
i knew it was a good day after that then
the celebration broke out
oh yeah celebration broke out my mom was
crying everybody was just just uh happy
for me and then when did you realize
that you were going to get a
considerable opportunity with this team
elijah mitchell when did that
first hit you're like okay um it's not
just going to be a learning curve it's
going to be an actual
uh real live competition curve for you
when did that happen um
i think um as i can remember uh i think
it was right before the season started
uh
i started getting like uh um reps with
the ones and stuff and then right there
i knew like uh
i might have a role
so uh that was another time that i was
very grateful for okay and we've heard
quite a bit about uh the practice
uh habits and or expectation level of
players from san francisco and certainly
i had debo on the show last week and i
asked him about brandon ayuk and how
um for him this year even though it was
his second year was a bit of an
eye-opener on that front what about
you and the running back group
in san francisco what what are you told
about uh how to go about being a
professional elijah mitchell oh really
uh really when i first got here uh
like uh juice and like rahim and uh
jeff wilson they'll just always talk
about uh make sure you you have your
details down and make sure you be locked
in because it's all about details uh
you got to be in the right right
position
the right alignment everything's because
everything happened for a reason so uh
that was a big thing for our room so
they spread that to us and
i just had to be a sponge and and go for
it how difficult is that what
the degree of difficulty is
it was something it was something i was
i was i had to get used to because uh at
first i really
i really didn't know anything about
being like very detailed so uh once i
caught on it was just
it was just i just started rolling from
there no obviously we we always talk
about a physical aspect of this game but
it's that's part of the reason why
football is so remarkable is the neck up
part of it that that muscle that you
have in between your temples is so
important and certainly in a system that
we keep talking about that is exotic is
the word we usually use
elijah mitchell about the offense that
you're playing in right now so what
adjustment level has that been for you
in general
for you uh yeah uh you definitely have
to bring it uh mentalized because uh
it's the game so fast you gotta know
what you're doing you don't have time to
think so you really got to be on
everything on your p's and q's so that's
something that i stress a lot
and uh still getting used to now so uh
but it's been been going really well for
me elijah mitchell here the san
francisco 49ers on the rich eisen show
who's the most grown-ass man that you've
met in the whole this uh
this season so far in your first 12
weeks
coming through the hole and there's that
guy standing there who's that guy
elijah
i have to say i really i really haven't
met anybody yet that okay i have to go
through the hole with so okay
all right so and because are you the one
who's doing the punishing is that your
way of saying that elijah no not not
really it's just i just never had like a
head on head with any linebacker you
know specifically that's because you're
schemed into the open space huh that way
yeah that's right boys do a good job
getting them out the way that's right
your guys do give you a clear spot in
your clear space what is it like in the
locker room this last month compared to
the first
of the season oh
yeah uh now the locker room everybody
was happy and stuff because of course we
won but uh
not fans beginning
it's just like you expect uh nobody's
happy everybody's down because we know
we better you're better than what we
played so uh now i'm starting to click
and you gotta keep it rolling and what
about the the uh the responsibility
that's being placed on you elijah how do
you handle that because it's clear that
you're you're the guy you're the guy
that's gonna get the rock you're the guy
that's gonna get the rock not just to
start but to end it and that is a that
is a crucially important position for
the san francisco 49ers
so how do you handle that one
elijah uh like i say uh i i go by
in the game we play the same either way
though but uh uh i'm happy for the
opportunity to call them uh trust me
captain the ball that many times and
like i said you gotta stay consistent
and keep it going who's your guy growing
up
who was your guy growing up when you
were rooting for football and who who
was the guy that you were saying i want
to be this guy when i get to the nfl or
that's the guy that inspired me to get
to the nfl do you have that guy man one
guy one guy that i watched for football
being a running back barry sanders that
that guy that that that is an awesome
running back
why why i mean how old are you i mean
you're not i'm that's i'm i'm 23 years
old okay so you're
that's an old school name that you just
threw out at me elijah you were not
alive when barry was running like that
exactly is it uh
that just somebody well my my uh my high
school coach uh coach como he uh used to
always harper about that he showed me
film of him and ever since then i've
just been watching his highlights and
stuff and man just the way he moves and
make people miss that's just something
that
i want to do and something that i wanted
to do so uh
that was the god that i watched okay
that's interesting so no no new orleans
saints did you grow up a saints fan were
you or is it uh
yeah uh i definitely wear the saints fan
uh
but uh now he's like i
i'm a san francisco right now i
understand that no i i totally i totally
understand that i'm just trying to see
if there was anybody on the saints that
you were growing up so it's barry
sanders you're watching cut-ups of barry
sanders when you were growing up there
okay
um well look elijah what do you what
what are your two cents on um on your
your collegiate football program losing
your coach to florida what did you think
about that elijah i say uh man uh like i
said he uh
coach napier he deserves everything man
like he did awesome job coming in and
even when i was uh in college uh
when he came in and changed everything
for us so i feel like i wouldn't be in
the position i'm in now it wasn't for
him coming in changing the scheme and
everything so
like i say uh
that those guys at the the players at
the school they they understand the deal
and they know he's an awesome coach so
uh like i say it's time for him to go so
uh good luck to him with that the word
super bowl being mentioned around your
parts at all do you hear those words
mentioned
for your team oh most definitely that's
that's that's that's the goal that's
that's the number one goal that we have
super votes so so how how's it brought
up you guys just say we're going to it
or i think we can do it you hear your
guys from two years ago saying this
reminds them of the season where they
they went to it anything like that yeah
also yeah uh 2019 we they we always talk
about that two of my teams got to get
back to
uh where he was in 2019 so uh that's
something that we harp on and i gotta
say we gotta keep making this run so
that can happen all right well uh i'll
help you out because you called into the
show and i greatly appreciate that
elijah mitchell uh there's somebody
named bobby wagner named uh number 54
i'll help you circle him um that's
that's a guy that you're going to see
coming up um in your next game on sunday
night he might be that guy in the hole
so you look out for him you keep your
head on the swivel for him okay
okay and then if you if you do in fact
you know get past him run him over
whatever i'll i'll i'll take credit for
that how does that sound yeah is that
fine
that
sounds good i appreciate that thank you
elijah mitchell you take care of
yourself thanks for the day thanks for
the call appreciate it oh yeah we'll do
you guys elijah mitchell hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here